il y avait de l'amour dans l'air lors du
spectacle des finissants de l'école
nationale de l'humour
genève est un
art est un show de mon style c'est le
fun on s'envoie verts d'un côté positif
les salles ray ou concret nous mêmes
l'humour de demain ici nous moi je
pourrais te suit n'importe quel gars
avec toute la côte qui agit sous le pied
c'est comique on étudie l'art de la
blague pendant deux ans et pandémie
oblige ça s'est passé en bonne partie
sur internet les hommes ni personne
[Musique]
n'est pas la chose la plus facile de me
concentrer sur un réseau ça a été plus
difficile mais on avait tellement une
belle cour d'appel tendu si j'aurai la
compétition sera forte pour ces
finissants car après le confinement ça
se bouscule aux portes pour monter sur
scène avec leur diplôme en poche ces
artistes de la relève devront se tailler
une place dans les bars et sur le web
encore des projets et puis on est
vraiment parti c'est pas un taux de
placement est dans le projet comme
continuer à faire des trucs qui a aidé
rôle et s'amuser hyundai qui me frappe
et qui a enlevé mon haut de maillot jeté
ne bouge j'ai vécu la première vague
mitul dans sept corps de la pandémie il
n'y a visiblement pas de membres de
communautés culturelles et parmi les
quatorze finissant il ya seulement deux
femmes c'est tellement bizarre des deux
filles
c'est moins que le minimum pour moi
une paix c'est trop bizarre deux filles
je sais pas ça tellement était besoin ça
me dit que c'est pas beaucoup mais je
vais vers rétorqué en vous disant que la
nouvelle corde qui vient d'entrer
d'humoristes deux premières années il ya
sept filles et 6 go on explique des
affaires ma blonde petit - j'écoute pich
poser question mais j'écoute est
important d'écouter les lions de vous
donnerai les nouveaux finissants de
l'école nationale de l'humour ont soif
de monter sur scène et ils peuvent
compter sur l'appui de catherine levac
qui assistaient à leur spectacle
début
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié
[Musique]
touchant il avait beau les gens
vaisselle sur l'épaule toujours savez
jamais vu de vaisselle solange là en ces
temps incertains l'humour est un des
remèdes à la grisaille car parfois il
vaut mieux en rire que d'en pleurer
essaye de mieux manger je frenche très
bien chez la nourriture rouge fait pas
de miettes ma technique est excellent
oui philippe ouimet radio canada